Thank You Matt and thanks all for
welcoming back welcoming me back here
on campus it is a very special place to
me I love this picture I had a lot more
hair back then that's my dad who is kind
enough to put me through this place it's
astonishing to me when I reflect back
every time I walk on this campus today
included every time I feel an
unbelievable sense of gratitude and and
just joy and happiness because this
place was such a special part of my life
and was absolutely a inflection point in
my life and so I hope you all are as
grateful for the experience and the
opportunity to be here I hope you all
have the same feeling I did when I was
17 years old walking on campus thinking
how the heck do I make the most of this
extraordinary institution and there's a
lot to do and a lot to do that but I
tell you the thing I remember I took I
took away most from my time here at
Stanford
were the people and the people are
amazing from the faculty that taught me
to fellow students and friends that I
made here and that's gonna be the theme
for everything I talked to you guys
about today is gonna be about people
because I believe that is at the center
of what building great businesses and
being a great leader is all about and as
future entrepreneurs I'm sure that is a
topic of great interest I will get the
quick overview just so you know a little
bit about us and who we are where we
come from as matt said I was privileged
enough to go join SendGrid about three
plus years ago we were small probably
about a thirty million dollar company
then maybe three and a half years ago we
did just have a great successful IPO
we're really excited about and proud of
but it all comes down to these these
three guys up on the screen who were the
entrepreneurs that got SendGrid started
back in 2009 Tim Isaac and Jose
wonderful guys that had we're serial
entrepreneurs and had been developers
building new websites and products and
every time they did that every one of
those websites if you've ever as a
consumer gone in to sign up for a new
service you might recognize the pattern
where you type in an email address and
they send you a confirmation
an email and you click on that email and
it says okay now you're logged in and
you can go and access the site it turned
out to actually solve that very basic
problem as a developer building the app
just that little button that says I
forgot my password and you click on that
button there's code that has to sit
behind it to deliver that message back
to you as a user in an automated fashion
and as developers they found that they
were spending months and tens of
thousands of dollars setting up servers
and learning these protocols around
email like SMTP and D command D mark
stuff that nobody should know developers
should know it should need to know about
they recognize this problem and said hey
this is really frustrating and annoying
because even after all that work about
40% of their email was ending up in the
spam folder or getting dropped by the
inbox provider somebody like a Gmail or
Yahoo because they didn't know how to
actually set it all up so they decided
let me go build this out in the cloud
and we're gonna be able to deliver this
email and let me just go see if if we do
that are there any other people on the
planet that have that problem it turned
out that it was a ubiquitous problem
absolutely the you know a huge
horizontal need by literally millions of
developers all over the planet and we've
been fortunate in being able to serve
many of the largest brands digital
brands in the world to help them engage
with their users if anybody here has if
you've ever received a receipt from uber
after you got out of the ride send grids
delivering that on their behalf if you
get a confirmation when you make a
reservation with Airbnb you get
recommended playlists from Spotify all
of those are powered by sin grid's
platform and we do that for tens of
thousands of customers nearly sixty
thousand businesses around the world in
over a hundred countries now on boohoo
on their behalf we're sending nearly a
trillion emails life to dates we send
about for over a billion emails every
single day
it's an extraordinary reach we touch 3
billion unique recipients every year
which is more than half of the world's
online population and and we're just
getting started
so we're
really excited about the business but
that's that is one example of an
extraordinary I think success story from
three humble beginnings three founders
who had an idea and said I'm gonna go go
after it make it happen there's a lot
that I want to share with you all but I
want to get a quick read on the room a
raise your left side right side how many
of you expect to are participating in
now or expect to start a company as an
entrepreneur in the next 12 months just
want to get a read of the room okay and
how many of you on the right side expect
to join a company that may be an
entrepreneurial venture may be young
stage hands okay probably another third
and others that may go to something
later stage or are currently working
later stage okay so it's mostly in those
first two buckets so but interestingly
almost an even mix in this room of the
entrepreneurs themselves they're gonna
go get something started and and folks
that are entrepreneurial and both both
matter I will tell you I'm 23 years now
into my career I haven't yet founded a
company interestingly this is my second
CEO job I was employee number six of my
first startup but I wasn't actually the
founder I was brought in to help help
build it and this company I joined you
know five years in I still think of
myself as being very entrepreneurial
because I love to create and I love to
build and so for those in the room who
weren't in the I'm gonna go start
something in the next 12 months by all
means you still absolutely can leverage
all of the entrepreneurial lessons that
an entrepreneur is going to go through
and frankly I still aspire to go and
start my own thing at some point and I
believe that all the lessons learned in
the last 23 years will help me in in
that endeavor so I wanted to share with
you some of those lessons in the hopes
that it will help you either in your
launching point for your for your
entrepreneurial venture if you're
getting started now or at you think
about how to be entrepreneurial inside
of some other organization and what I
would tell you is that I know when I was
in your shoes I spent a lot of time as a
business guy and somebody who aspired to
be a business guy wanting to really
understand
the hard skills of business I really
wanted to learn about strategy and I
read Michael Porter stuff and you know
target addressable markets right Tam's
and Sam services service markets and
what's the competitive landscape and how
do you think about market structure and
thinking about innovation and disruption
and all the great work that clay
Christensen's done and you want to learn
about financials and what's the right
financial structure for any given
business which through their
capitalization look like all the hard
skills which by the way are super
important and very interesting and I
will tell you that they are all
necessary but not sufficient necessary
but not sufficient and sufficiency at
the end of the day comes from something
that most people would describe as a
soft skill and I will tell you I'm here
to say definitively there's nothing easy
about this it is hard there's nothing
soft about it and this is where when I
think back over my 23 years of all the
things I learned it was every single
lesson usually came back to focus on the
people focus on people and and I want to
give you there probably half a dozen
examples of this that I want to share
with you that have really informed the
way that I have been able to develop and
challenges I've been able to overcome
and and things that I still hope to get
better at because this is I believe in
its essence what business is all about
because and I love this quote I think it
it tees it up quite well business you
don't build a business you build people
that then go and build a business and if
you focus and so that theme by the way
focus on people you're gonna hear me say
that about six times throughout the rest
of the day I want to get to a point
where you can tell you can tell I'm
about to go there and you're gonna
you're gonna play it back for me and say
yeah focus on people because that is the
one message I know you guys get to hear
a lot of extraordinary folks come and
present from this from this lectern and
it's gonna be hard to remember all the
things if literally those three words
this is this is all I want you to take
away and I hope the examples and the
anecdotes will live with you but those
are the three words focus on
people three months from now I hope if I
were to bump into you and down on
University Ave I said what I talked
about you'd say focus on people that's
it it's super simple because that is
really how you build great businesses so
for those who said hey I'm gonna go be
an entrepreneur I want to get started
you're gonna focus on people let me give
you some examples of the very first
thing you got to do is choose your
co-founders there is no more important
decision literally in terms of order of
importance of decisions this priority
one two three four five and probably six
are choose the right business partner
building and entrepreneurial ventures
extraordinarily difficult and if you get
that wrong the rest of its don't bother
is extraordinarily difficult and the key
thing ironically I that I believe goes
wrong in a lot of those in a lot of that
process has nothing to do with the hard
skills of well I'm the business person
in there the technology person we got
the right skills matrix across it's not
that it's do we line up on values do we
see the world the same way do we know
what kind of company we want to go build
together not in what we do but in how we
do it those are very different things so
you got to go get lined up first by
choosing a founder and a partner that
you have values with and by the way it
is and if you talk to founders who have
done this they will tell you it is no
joke as important a decision as who you
choose for your spouse because you're
gonna spend more time arguably with that
co-founder then you do with your spouse
for that in for that period of time that
you start building that company it is a
crazy and it's all about people and your
instinct around people and values it's a
soft skill but it's a very very
important one picking your investors
it's gonna be the same thing it's not
gonna be a maybe you know one of the
factors in your decisions may be how
well capitalized are they do they have a
great brand name it's going to come down
to you and should come down to what is
the relationship that I have with the
particular partner at the firm that is
going to engage with me because that's
gonna be the person who's in the room
with me
in my darkest hours
and brightest days and I have to be I
get a that person's in might is is on my
side in the trenches with me you got to
be able to pick that person wisely and
well and it's not easy to do so you're
gonna focus on on people there are so
many lessons here that that I have seen
over the years wound if you are an
entrepreneur what I would encourage you
to do around people things let's get
past now we picked our fad our
co-founder we've found our capital
source to get this thing off the ground
to many companies I would argue wait too
long to go and establish what kind of
values do we want to have as a culture
as a business as we scale SendGrid
fortunately made the decision to invest
in that at the very very outset and the
reason it matters I'll get to the next
topic is because the people you are
going to attract will be immensely based
on values and culture and if it's not by
the way you'll end up with a course
correction downstream but if you can get
it right from the outset literally sit
down and think about with your partner
what kind of values do we want to
represent as a business and then we can
we can proceed from there and build a
culture around that let me let me give
you some examples for SendGrid
specifically we have a culture based on
something we call the four H's happy
hungry humble and honest what those are
and they are core to the way we the way
we built our business the way we run our
business how we interact with one
another it shows up in every meeting
room and every interaction and every
review done this is how we live and work
together and it's and it's very clear
it's not just up on the whiteboard but I
will tell you I've seen a lot of
companies and and founder ting teams
even when they do think about doing it
early they'll write down 13 things I
don't know about you I'm not smart
enough to remember 13 things I just
can't but four H's
well that's easy I got that happy hungry
humble and honest okay even I can
remember that and by the way so can the
other 425 people that work at SendGrid
and so keeping it simple is super
important if I were just to give you
some advice on if you're thinking about
this as an entrepreneur I would say keep
it simple and and memorable also make
sure that it has some edge so it can't
be motherhood and apple pie it can't be
that any person in the labor market and
the talent market would come to and fit
into that culture and I will tell you I
have worked in software for 23 years now
and I have so many extraordinary
professionals and friends who would work
at working at SendGrid would be their
seventh hell they would absolutely
detest it and particularly that humble h
would knock out a bunch of
extraordinarily talented people that
I've worked with in my past but that's
just not the way they would want to
operate our humble age is all about we
not I it is team-based it has so many
characteristics to it that just would
screen out a whole set of people we do
our interviewing and we ask you about
you know what's the thing you're most
proud of that you've accomplished to
date and you literally do a pronoun
count how many times do they say I and
how many times do they say we and that
is a perfect screen and filter for us if
are they aligned to our kind of values
people can say I all they and be super
successful in lots of other companies
and our company that's not going to work
so your your culture has to have some
edge to it the second thing that I would
encourage is you think about building
values and culture if you're an
entrepreneur give your new teammates a
uniform give them a uniform this may
sound like a ridiculously tactical knit
and I will tell you I think it's one of
the most powerful things done by any
team because again as an entrepreneur
think of what you are doing is amassing
a group of people and getting them into
be forging them into being a team that
is gonna go take some Hill together
right think about the greatest teams
whether it's in athletics the military
and you pick
your walk of life where you'd see a team
it is highly common that they have a
uniform and so it's SendGrid
we serve a lot of we go to lots of
hackathons we serve literally hundreds
of thousands of developers around the
world we hand out these blue SendGrid
t-shirts I think it's like something
like 10,000 a year to developers but
these blue hoodies josè one of our
founders is wearing this blue hoodie is
given to each new employee and only two
employees those hoodies are like these
prized possessions and they show up on
your very first day you get your laptop
your key card and your blue hoodie and
you walk into any of our offices and
you'll see on the coat rack lots and
lots of these hoodies it's a it's a
uniform they feel part of something that
is larger than themselves
right as they say like in athletics
you'll often hear great coaches say you
play for the name on the front of the
Jersey not on the back it's not about
your name it is about the team's name
that's who we play for creating that
mindset amongst the teammates and the
business you're about to build I would
argue is critically critically important
building connective tissue is a
catchphrase that we talk about a lot
it's Indrid it sounds kind of hokey
again soft skills people's stuff I
believe that there is no investment too
large for us to make in building
connections across our teammates where
they get to know each other as people as
human beings not just colleagues
so we invest in things like this giant
picture here is you notice the beach in
the background every January we fly the
entire company down to Mexico and Kabul
in this this case is Cabo other years
different places but we get the entire
company together in January by the way
we do it again in June and we have a
full day and day and a half actually of
content and alignment hard hard business
stuff and then we have a day where folks
just hang there just by the pool too
they're going and playing beach
volleyball together they're going
kayaking together but building
relationships where they actually care
about each other as human beings when
you come back into the workplace you now
start playing for those teammates at a
whole different level at a whole
different level because you've got a
connection to them that is very
different so we invest a lot of time and
a lot of money in these things and you
go all the way down to interest groups
we've got a you know wine lovers group
and a outdoors activity group and you
know you but you guess you create
opportunities for folks to get to know
one another as as people and then
finally I would say whatever you land on
as your values and your culture
celebrate when you see great behavior
reflecting it so we instituted a handful
of years back a recognition program of
and so in our case we call them the 4-h
awards in every single quarter we gather
all of our employees together and we go
through all the business updates and
here's how we're doing against our goals
and our initiatives and our score you
know scorecards we're tracking
everything and interspersed throughout
that couple hour meeting are these
4-h awards their peer recognition awards
so it's all nominated from any one of
the 425 teammates to say I believe this
person deeply reflects and embodies our
4-h values and here's why and they write
these nominate these nomination forms it
almost brings me to tears when I read
them they're so beautiful
like when you see and hear one teammate
so deeply appreciating another you can
tell we got something special here these
people really enjoy working with one
another and then as this picture
represents our SVP assails handing this
award out to one of our product
marketing folks you put this we
literally play on a screen that wide
we've got two of them on either side and
whoever nominated in this case nominated
Joanna for the award and by the way the
selection committee is a peer nominated
committee the executives the management
team know VPS are involved it's all
based on your peers
and they read through all these
nominations and they select for every
quarter and you know folks can get get
them throughout the year they then
whoever wins whoever is selected by the
committee they then go back to the
nominate ORS and say hey can you create
a video and nowadays you pull out your
iPhone and they do all sorts like these
videos are hilarious sometimes they
bring you to tears because they're so
touching but they do these videos of all
the people who have nominated that
person and by the way wisdom of the
crowds often point to these folks they
turn out to be it's obvious who are the
folks that are embodying this behavior
and then you put it you play these
videos on screens this size 30 feet wide
on both sides I can't think of another
way to signal to our company how much we
care about our values then 30 foot wide
videos of their teammates describing how
much it means to them to work with
somebody that lives our values and it
changes behavior and I'll tell you I've
heard plenty of times like yeah I I want
to live I want to make sure that I'm
doing that I want to be like that person
and it's unbelievably powerful so these
are just a handful of ideas just very
tangible tactical things you could do if
you're an entrepreneur getting started I
would encourage you to think about
values and culture on day one because I
really believe deeply that when you when
you focus on people and you get
everybody there aligned in their values
and they love working with one another
companies that have that win races and I
love the rowing metaphor if my teammates
were here they'd be like oh dude not
another rowing metaphor but I love crew
because it is the ultimate example of
teamwork I think this visual is the
butyl is the most beautiful expression
of it because as if you're in a tiny
little crew boat if you're our oars
aren't hitting the water at the exact
same moment you're not going to go
anywhere right or you're gonna be going
in different directions if right the
timing is off if you're not in sync so
getting everybody aligned is one piece
of it and then you've got them get
in sync and that's great anybody here
read this read this book boys in the
boat came out a couple of years ago a
few years ago of the 1936 Olympics crew
team out of the University of Washington
that was extraordinary as this great
book and I loved this quote from the
book that was in its essence it wasn't
just about the athletes in the boat
relative you know in terms of physical
stature and size strength whatever that
made them such a special crew it was
this thing was that their teammates open
their hearts to each other they cared
about each other and so they played at a
whole different level and I am Telling
You business is the exact same way every
entrepreneurial venture if you were
gonna go be a leader and that you want
to build that environment where a team
feels like I am gonna play at a
different level for these teammates
because they know my whole self I have
been vulnerable in front of them they
know who I am they know what I'm about
they know how I approach things and I
care about them and so I want to deliver
for them I'm not gonna let them down
that is a whole different ballgame if
you can build a team forge a team out of
individuals remember these are every
employee if you're getting started as a
entrepreneurial venture these are
strangers they show up all right they've
never met each other these are
individuals that your job as an
entrepreneur is to forge them into not
just a team but a crazy high functioning
team that is going to go faster than any
other group of people and any other team
going after the same thing you are and
this is I believe a huge part of how you
do that is they care about each other
they care about each other I wrote this
in in our s-1 when we filed to go public
it's a rather unusual paragraph to find
in a financial document submitted to the
SEC I said I believe that values create
value that a huge part of why SendGrid
has been successful to date is because
of all that soft stuff that I just went
through that's why we are now worth over
a billion dollars we've had a lot of
other things go right all the other
stuff I mentioned the necessary
but not sufficient when we got those
things right - but this is the part that
I believe creates value and I believe
that if you get this right you have a
competitive advantage over every other
team that is trying to go after the same
thing you are another example on
focusing on people and why it is so
important as you think about this if
you're an entrepreneur getting started
recruiting recruiting I believe is
thought about incorrectly by 95% of
companies I happen to be fortunate in
joining a company in 1995 straight out
of this place that was led by a founder
CEO who I believe was in the 5% that
deeply understood this and said
recruiting is a mission-critical
function for our business and there's
nothing more important that we are doing
than hiring great people that is like
that is absolutely core it is not my my
side task a obligation that I may or may
not get to it was priority number one
he signaled it in his own behavior Joe
would literally be on a call with a 21
year old kid out of Stanford out of MIT
out of CMU or Rice amongst the best CS
departments and grads in the country
convincing them that they had to come
join us on our journey down a trilogy in
Austin Texas they had to come and they
were gonna make a difference and and he
hung up the phone and by the way as a
signal that we were doing the right
thing you would know a couple hours
later that same kid was getting a phone
call from a guy named Bill Gates because
Gates understood and built Microsoft
from day one around that same philosophy
that talent was everything and he
personally and by the way by that time
even in 1995 Microsoft was already a
multi-billion dollar revenue company and
he was still picking up the phone and
calling 21 year old kids straight out of
school because he
new that is the lifeblood of your
company if you can win the war and
talent everything else changes and so
there's just lots and lots of examples
about how again focus on people focus on
people and you'll build an extraordinary
business in our case and because by the
way I love this quote from Jim Collins
book I'm sure a lot of folks here in the
room read good to great that the only
great regulator of building great
companies at the end of the day is
getting attracting and then keeping
great people like that is usually the
ultimate constraint it is not any of
these other things that he enumerates
here it is about being able to do that
and so when I got to send grid a handful
of years ago I wanted to make sure that
we were bringing that same passion
around recruiting that I was fortunate
enough to grow up with to be exposed to
early and to me when I was 21 I was like
well I had never seen anything else so I
just assumed that's what most companies
did I saw for the rest of my career that
that actually was not the way that most
companies worked around recruiting that
people often thought about recruiting as
the thing I have to do after my day job
and I've already got a full plate and I
don't know when I'm gonna be able to fit
this in and they thought about it as an
obligation and one of the things we had
to do is flip that back no no no
recruiting is a privilege because that
means we as a company all your teammates
here saying we choose you to go
represent us to go convince the best
talent out there that they want to come
join us and to go and filter and make
calls on what I believe is the single
most important decision we make every
single week week in and week out and
that is who we decide to give the next
hoodie to because you get that right you
get one 10x you know what they call
these 10 Xers you know somebody that is
a distinctive ad for the role you need
and it's a game changer for that whole
function for that whole team sometimes
for your whole company you get that
thing wrong and getting the wrong hire
making that decision incorrectly
expensive and painful and you can it's
again it's all about the people so
focusing on the people so privileged
recruiting czar privilege not an
obligation I felt so passionately about
this anybody remember the movie Jerry
Maguire and I can't remember age groups
here but he like you know so I wrote a
the equivalent of a Jerry Maguire
manifesto on why recruiting was so
important as a six page document and I
sent it out to our team and I said this
is how passionately I believe
let's now debate every line in here
until we feel comfortable it represents
our collective view and then we sent it
out to the entire company and we said
recruiting is everyone's number one
priority I never want to hear we
couldn't do that interview slate or we
lost that candidate because we couldn't
get enough people together for the
interview and they took another job with
somebody else it is our number one
priority always and if you come to me
and say this project Sameer slipped by
three days because this team of people
went and did that interviewing I will
say Bravo thank you for doing that good
call that's how I know you're you're
prioritizing the way that I would want
you to and so we we made that deeply
embedded into the organization and then
actually helping our teammates
understand that when we're doing the
interviewing again for the entrepreneurs
this was a super temp super tempting and
easy pitfall to fall into is you hire
for talent and you Bend on culture and
value fit and you can't do it and you
will be so tempted because you're just
trying to get this thing off the ground
and you will come across somebody that
is a badass at what they do
pardon my language and they'll not
represent say in our case the humble age
and you'll be so tempted back oh they
would just kill it on this project and
we need somebody that knows this random
esoteric skill said and they've got it
and let's let's just get him and see
like we'll coach him he'll be can't do
it you can't do it never do it I just
please put that back away in your brain
someday you will get that situation and
please remember don't do it the bar
raiser anybody
heard about Amazon's program around bar
razors anybody know interesting so
Amazon has had this for a long time at
trilogy literally back in the mid 90s we
had a program called the sponsor program
and we basically said there's going to
be a silhouette man back to a privilege
a select group of people who have
demonstrated inability to keep the bar
high and then they get absolute veto
power on an interview on a candidate so
they're in every slate of interviews has
to have a bar raiser or a sponsor on the
slate and if everybody else said yes and
the bar raiser said no the answer is no
even if the hiring manager is the one
saying yes the bar raiser vetoes and
that is how you make sure you continue
to hire the absolute best people for the
kinds of roles you want because it is
very easy when you are going like this
you're growing fast or there's more work
to do than you could possibly imagine to
lower the bar to get a butt in seat as
they say you can't do it
so some just very tactical advice around
recruiting it's all about the people you
get this stuff right and it makes a
extraordinary difference in the
probability of success of your
entrepreneurial venture here's another
one
focus on people when those people when
you go out you've gone through all okay
we've gotten we felt we picked our
founder wisely we got the right VC
partner that we think is going to be a
great in the trenches person with us we
defined our culture and our values made
it memorable and simple it gave people
uniforms we celebrate those wins we
build connective tissue let's say you've
got you've gone through and done all
that and then you get all the recruiting
stuff right once they have now joined
you how do you then treat them and my
strong counsel to you is if you're built
as an entrepreneur you're getting this
thing started treat them like owners not
employees if you can get we talk about
this as anger at all the time we want
all four hundred and twenty five of our
grit errs that's what we call ourselves
critters
all grit errs to act like owners and
what the way that owners act I always
joke about this this visual anybody ever
seen a rental car at a car wash nobody
has ever seen a rental car to car wash
because they're not owners they don't
give two hoots about right then however
that's that's the rental car companies
business how do you treat the rental car
versus your own car it an owner acts
differently and so I I would encourage
and we do this at SendGrid every
employee has equity make them owners
have a conversation about what that
means to be an owner because what it
means to be an owner is you sweat the
details you care differently then it's
just a job if you see a problem you
don't go assume that somebody else is
gonna fix it you go fix it
because you're an owner owners act
differently and then you say for all
those folks that I just made owners I
said hey I'm gonna teach you to be
owners we're gonna give you equity etc
kitchen to the right headspace then the
hardest thing is especially as you grow
maintaining a mindset where you empower
those owners empowering the owners means
you figure out how do you get every
decision that can be done by your
individual contributors should be they
are closest to the work they are closest
to the problem and so if you can empower
those owners and this this visual image
that last trip to Mexico and 2017 I
spent about 15 minutes
talking to all of our griggers 400
people in a room about manufa out of
oble manufacturing in 1950s Japan I like
did what are you what what why are you
telling about we're in software I don't
know if you notice like why are we going
through this and the Toyota Production
system though is an incredibly
instructive model how many folks are
familiar with TPS anybody in the room a
lot of folks fair a number of folks it's
an extraordinarily efficient way to
manufacture things great quality results
safety results cetera for me
the sole of the importance of the Toyota
Production system is the act being
demonstrated in this photo which is
pulling the and on court and what that
means is there is a line worker on the
factory floor that may be being paid
minimum wage and you are empowering that
person to say there is something wrong
here on the line I am pulling that cord
and we are gonna stop we're gonna shut
down a line that will cost us hundreds
of thousands probably millions of
dollars for every 30 minutes that it is
shut down and you are gonna empower this
line person to make that call and Toyota
in the production system would say
absolutely they're the people closest to
the work and its software true just in
manufacturing the earlier you fix the
problem the less expensive it is to go
figure it out to to go rectify it so
empower your folks and and this was
great because the entire year in 2017
after this story I had people sharing
examples of hey you know that person
pulled the end on court on this problem
and we gathered a tiger and by the way
in that system when somebody pulls the
end on court people that are teammates
and leaders flock to the problem they're
like okay the lines shut down let's go
figure out what happened how can we help
you how can we I mean they first by the
way the very first thing they say to the
person that pulled the cord is thank you
thank you for pulling to court now how
can we help you and people flock to it
and they figure it out and then you move
on and so anyways throughout the year we
had so many examples of people that
would pull the cord and then they became
to use it in our in our vocabulary at
SendGrid
we're gonna pull the end on court on
this we got to stop doing what we're
doing go gather solve the problem and
then we'll let the run line run again
and so we started to celebrate those
victories at every quarterly meeting
when we got everybody together and we
would tell those stories and it would
reinforce to the entire company we're
not just talking about this stuff in
platitudes we are doing it every day and
we're celebrating it when one of our
teammates actually pulls the cord we're
not just talking about empowering
empowerment of our employees for the
sake of saying it like
it actually matters and then you
celebrate the wins what that all leads
to I would argue is a super important
mindset about leadership I will be the
first to admit this is not for everyone
but this is a world view of leadership
that I deeply appreciate it is how I
aspire to lead it is not easy
necessarily to do but it basically takes
the typical org chart and says in a
world where I have spent a lot of time
thinking about my values and recruiting
the best talent and Ivan enabled them
and power them said hey gotta act like
owners the role of the leader of the
entrepreneur the founder CEO it is not
the typical org chart with the CEO at
the top that cascades to the exec team
the cascades to the VP's and down out to
the organization in that pyramid I
actually believe it's inverted it should
go this way with the CEO and the
executive leadership team at the bottom
that are supporting the hard work of the
people that actually do the hard work of
the company every day because let me be
clear and for those of you who will be
founders and entrepreneurs I am NOT
trying to dismiss how difficult that job
is if you're the CEO of a company trust
me I'm with you it's hard we make we
have to do a lot of things right if you
go back to that boat analogy I would
argue we've got the rudder we're
steering we got a steer into the right
markets all right we got to make sure
we've got the right product set the
right portfolio are we competitive do we
have the right cap structure can we keep
playing we got to get we got to do a
bunch of things right but but remind
yourself of this you don't take the
phone call when a customer's pissed
that's somebody in your technical
support organization right you don't
have to hit the quota that your sales
rep does you don't have the pressure
that the software engineer has to
deliver on that project by this
deliverable day so we can get that out
into the market and remember that so on
mass that those are the folks who do the
hard work of your business every day you
may make some hard decisions in the
steering but they do the hard work and
so I believe our jobs as servant leaders
should be to remove obstacle
and help them go and do their best work
I believe in our company if we remove
those obstacles and we let four hundred
and twenty some odd people do their best
work and have career highs that's in
grid there's no one that's gonna stop us
we're gonna continue to build an
extraordinary company because you unlock
and unleash 420 owners going after
something that they want to accomplish
and they care about each other to go do
it that's a force to be reckoned with
and I love it and so I think this model
is incredibly powerful I do think it's
actually super simple to understand it
is in effect the golden rule applied to
leadership or management imagine try to
be the kind of leader that you would
want to work for if you're an
entrepreneur CEO that's how you should
be thinking about it if I had a boss I
don't want that bus well I'd probably
want that boss to have provide me with
super clear goals so I knew what success
looked like I want them to really help
me in that endeavor and if there were
things in my way help me understand them
better or unblock them I'd want them to
care about me as a as a whole person
that they actually cared about me not
just for me delivering for this period
of time but for my my life my career arc
that's what I would want so that's the
kind of person that I think I should be
as a leader and what I hope our
leadership team emulates and every
leader up the chain that's the way I
believe you actually build great
companies now all that said for all
those in the room or like I'm I'm not
actually starting a company in the next
twelve months but if you were like me
you might be in this in you know in at
that stage in life where you're gonna be
looking to join a company and I
encourage you to internalize the
absolute truth that you can be
entrepreneurial without being an
entrepreneur and guess what all the
lessons that I just talked about anybody
want to guess what I'm gonna say you
should do to be entrepreneurial focus on
people focus on people so let me give
you some examples what would I do what
what I try to
you again necessary but not sufficient
you should absolutely go and understand
is you're looking out to join a company
over the next how you know when you
graduate in June or whatever it is yeah
you should understand how strong is the
company what are their financials look
like what's their competitive set you
know going if it's a public company go
and read their their earnings
transcripts really learn about the
business I which I encourage you to do
if it's a smaller company go and try to
read third-party information about them
that's unbiased really understand the
business I absolutely encourage you to
do that and then go focus on the people
start with values and culture how do
what how do they live their values how
does that represent us itself in their
culture and does that line up with you
cuz let me tell you I don't care if
you're an entrepreneur or a new employee
of a great company you are gonna spend a
lot of hours at this place at this place
of work more so than you're gonna be
sleeping right so you want it to be a
place where you are aligned with the
values of the place that you are joining
right if you're not founding it doesn't
matter you still want to be lined up on
values and culture and really ask them
about that ask them about how they how
that shows up in their world and that's
true at a company level for sure when
you think about recruiting be a talent
magnet you join the company bring more
with you right one of the great great
signals of somebody who is going to be a
rising star in a company is are they
able to attract talent can be as appear
once you become a manager can be on your
team but a huge part of being a leader
is can you create followership of great
talent and that can be true when you're
21 years old just starting out and it's
certainly true when when you're a CEO so
and you want to act like an owner once
you get there don't wait for folks to
tell you what to do if you see a problem
go after it if you see
an opportunity the note I get I've you
know he when I think back to all the the
rising stars the folks that that were
extraordinary and the companies and
teams I worked at one of those common
threads is they were self starters they
took initiative they went beyond what
was asked of them in their normal day
job like here's the box and they were
doing stuff over here in addition they
did their box brilliantly well but they
did other stuff too that made the
company better because they were acting
like an owner and be empowered right
don't don't wait around for it like pull
that cord if you see a thing and I
guarantee you managers and leaders and
organizations see that set of behavior
and somebody new into their business
somebody that's like hey I care about
the values of how this place works and
I'm gonna act in accordance with that
and I'm gonna help attract more great
people to it and I'm gonna act like an
owner and be empowered those are the
folks that usually skyrocket through an
organization last couple comments here
and then I'm sure I'm running long but I
will you can we regardless of whether
you're a entrepreneur or being
entrepreneurial seek out mentors seek
out mentors they it is I think back on
my own career every opportunity I've
been blessed to receive every everything
every every success I've ever had has
been because of somebody either
willingness to take a bet on me or
giving me some great advice and coaching
and I just have so many examples of that
in the spirit of time oh I'll save them
but seeking out mentorship is is key my
closing comments to you why do I focus
on people so much I'll get through this
without getting too sentimental but
actually I won't Who am I kidding
that's a picture of my mom that's me is
a six month old nine month old I believe
my mom and she died when I was 15 just
before I came here and she was the best
example of a servant leader I have ever
seen people often hear servant leader
and they think that's kind of soft you
know back to the soft hard thing and
that's so soft
well actually the best servant leaders I
believe if you want to look for a great
example of a servant leader he'll look
to your parents parents are
extraordinary servant leaders they they
push you to be the absolute best that
you can be right they help you they do
everything they can to help you with
your journey right and boy let me tell
you they hold us accountable
I'm very remember being a kid not not
doing it not achieving what you could
have they hold you accountable it's not
about being soft their great servant
leaders and you know that they care
about you they know Leila that they love
us and so servant leadership to me for
me was embodied by by my mom and so I
just I saw the impact that's had on me
and my entire life I live my entire life
every day to try to make her proud and
so you you know like well that's a
pretty good example of somebody who had
a big impact on somebody how do I have
an impact on somebody else like that
well that's what she did so maybe if I
act in the same way with others I'll
have an impact too and she had this
great parable this old Indian parable
that she told my brother and I we're
little and it went something like you
know when we are babies we all enter
this world with our fists clenched
kicking and screaming and crying and
when we pass when we die we leave this
world with our hands open at peace what
we carry into this world in our hands
clenched in our fists as babies is a
unique and special gift that is to each
of us uniquely and the purpose of our
lives is to go and determine what that
gift is and then give of that gift to
others and then when you are done giving
your time will come and you will move on
and the soul of that parable that I
always love so much is about it's about
giving and it's about giving to others
focus on people and that's it that's my
one message I hope you remember it focus
on people thanks
sorry I ran a little long there I often
do as my teammates will tell you so
anybody has questions I am happy to take
them yeah the question was about when
you invest in those outings these all
company gatherings whether it's in
Mexico we actually do the beginning one
usually is is in a place like Mexico our
summer one we usually do and at near one
of our offices but the question was you
know how do you keep scaling that how
much do you decide how much time it
takes is it worthwhile and went at what
point do you scale out of it you know
we've gotten to 425 and I am still I
believe every nickel we spend on it is
worth it and then some and all the time
we spend around it is is worth it the
stuff that I don't like is you know the
inefficiency on travel and so sometimes
that that may take too long so we may
look at closer destinations in the
future but the time together I believe
is absolutely precious and I wouldn't I
wouldn't shortcut that our haircut that
at all any other questions
[Music]
yeah the question was really about how
you know are our values of those four
H's how they were get reflected in the
way we interact with our customers and
what that means for you know how we
actually serve the service that we
provide and what that might look like in
the future you know first and foremost I
would say the the wonderful thing about
attracting people that are 4-h is that
when you put those 4-h people in front
of customers with customers tend to
really like them because they are all
those they are happy hungry humble and
honest and let's just say it's a set of
things that our customers tend to very
much appreciate and again it's it's not
common they let the degree of as an
example on the honesty we will we
routinely like literally every month
dozens if not hundreds of customers get
a call or an alert or a notification or
an email from us that says you are going
to end up on the wrong plan based on
your sending patterns either up or down
and so if you may be spending too much
based on your sending and so we need to
upgrade you or the opposite you're
you're on a plan that is far in excess
of what you're actually sending you
might want to downgrade you're like I
don't think I've ever had a vendor do
that like wow that's that's our on stage
when we have issues we have outages
we're an infrastructure provider that
does happen not very much we had four
and a half nines a reliability we're
very proud of it but some you know
twenty four minutes out of every year we
have hiccups in those twenty four
minutes or shortly thereafter we are
deeply apologetic with our customers and
they hear it in our tone they know we
understand that this the service we are
providing you is mission critical to
your business if somebody doesn't get a
password reset in time or they don't get
a confirmation for a sign up they might
go off and do something
else and they lose that user forever and
so we get it and we're super we're
deeply sorry for that so I think they
they'd absolutely get reflected in the
interactions you know in terms of the
the product strategy as we go forward I
don't I can't I can't say that there's a
direct correlation between the four H's
and that as much as there is maybe the
Hungary eight shows up in that one
because we have big aspirations we are
excited to have crossed over a billion
dollar market cap line we aspire to
build a billion dollar revenue company
that's going to take it's a decade-long
journey we got a long way to go that's
great but well there are four four to
six other product categories that I
would expect us to be in in the next two
to three years so we absolutely will
expect to see us broaden our footprint
yes
work-life balance is is super important
to us that's actually the embodiment of
that happy H a big part of what we mean
by that we talk about having a positive
attitude constructive business is hard
it's how you show up and roll up your
sleeves and solve things and but a big
part of it is life is more than work and
if somebody is happy outside of work
they're more likely to be happy at work
I would tell you in in our honest age it
is the one of the four H's that I am
weakest at I have a lot over rotate on
the Hungary H and I'm a little bit under
rotated on that happy H of balance I
have two I have an amazing wife and two
wonderful kids my wife's a Stanford grad
herself and we've got 11 year old and an
8 year old and that is how work-life
balance happens is you know I've coached
soccer teams and basketball teams and
softball teams and and I love and I love
that and so for me all of my happy age
and balance comes from my family
you